heel vaak zijn mensen zich uitstekend bewust
van hun eigen gedrag
en van het negatieve effect daarvan
maar weten ze niet hoe ze eruit moeten komen
of het ontbreekt ze eenvoudigweg aan
het zelfvertrouwen om stappen te zetten
dan worstelen ze helemaal alleen en dat is tragisch
en vooral niet nodig
je mag er altijd vanuit gaan dat
alles waar jij mee worstelt
allang door iemand Anders doorleefd is
mensen praten vaak
over hun onzekerheden en kwetsbaarheden
alsof ze de enigen zijn
maar iedereen worstelt met soortgelijke dingen
dus die eenzaamheid die je kan ervaren in De Dingen die
moeilijk voor je zijn
die is niet nodig
we zijn als mens niet gemaakt
om dingen alleen op te lossen
dat is 1 aangeleerde perceptie
in 1 individuele maatschappij
als mens zijn we gemaakt om deel te zijn van 1 geheel
om te delen wat je bezighoudt
om te steunen en om te luisteren
oplossen hoeft niet
gewoon luisteren en er zijn